all this week we've focused on the
rising fire risk in the west the extreme
drought and the threat to farming and
wildlife
this morning five wildfires are burning
in utah and the governor has declared a
drought emergency there
the great salt lake is expected to reach
its lowest point in modern history
this year jonathan bigliotti shows how
the lack of water affects lives
and livelihoods in utah where many
farmers are struggling
just to keep their crops alive i don't
know
how long we can survive because i don't
know how bad it's going to get
on his property north of salt lake city
sixth generation farmer
ron gibson is covering his crops with
plastic
to conserve water his water allocation
was cut
by 70 percent if we don't get these
crops to market
we can't survive he also says the cost
of feeding his dairy cows
has doubled in a year when agriculture
is gone then our ability to produce food
is gone that's what scares me the most
about this whole situation
the entire state of utah is experiencing
drought
more than 90 percent in an extreme
category
we would be standing under water had
it been a normal water year we met zach
frankel
executive director of the utah rivers
council at the great salt lake
90 percent of our precipitation comes in
the winter and snow
as our winter air temperatures continue
to rise
we're getting less and less snow in our
mountains utah governor spencer cox has
declared
a state of emergency and called on
people in utah
to reduce their water use and pray for
rain
we need some divine intervention so when
the governor says
pray for rain what do you say to that i
say
the lord helps those who help themselves
and the question is
are state leaders willing to accept that
this is not a short-term drought
but that this is long-term climate
change
utah is the second driest state in the
country
but has some of the highest public water
consumption
per capita back on the farm gibson says
a continued water crisis means an
uncertain future
your family's been doing this for 152
years that's many generations do you
worry that this
is the last generation of farming in
your family you know i can't sleep at
night
and most nights because that's exactly
the concern
we're told this marina would normally be
floating on about 10
feet of water but like much of the state
it has dried up
utah feeds the colorado river and less
water in this state
means trouble downstream impacting
nearly 40 million people
in seven states for cbs this morning
jonathan vigliotti antelope island
in utah's great salt lake i don't know
how many more alarm bells you need you
know no
no i feel for him saying i can't sleep
at night next time we complain about
heavy rain think about the people that
would
really kill to have a big trench and
next time you open your fridge and you
see
fruit and you see vegetables think about
the farmers who are bringing that to us
i can't imagine being a farmer and
imagining like 150 years of
family farming may be coming to an end
here